you do such great impressions and what
your first impression was it of a beetle
yeah because I was 9 when they came out
do the math and you know in all of them
and it's become you know as Paul would
say shiny and brighter as they go along
you know but that was my first one at
age 9 I walk around the house doing that
he was talking there talking to Ed
Sullivan and I got that Liverpudlian
thing and I went up to my mom and said
am I'm 9 I go hello mom do you think you
could make me some pound cake just
because I love John Lennon and Paul
McCartney what they produce so much I
just do them talking to each other I
have them talking Paul explains Donald
Trump to John Lennon it was actually
loaded a vote for president Lula Vosges
didn't he's a big orange man you know
he's got little white circles around his
eyes and he's got a big tummy but he
puts a red tie over the tummy and his
hair just swirls around it's like an
orange really golden and if you look
close I see changes of purple and green
in his hair sounds like a dystopian
nightmare
[Laughter]
question yes you're in this this weird
world they know where you do an
impression of someone who's that famous
like a Paul McCartney and then I know
for a fact that you have met him many
times oh yeah what's that like when when
he's nothing he knows that you've done
him I know well I was a this doesn't ice
I'm mostly inside watching television
would be honest but I was at a
restaurant Lorne Michaels and Rob Lowe
yep and Lorne what hasn't been Oh Lauren
asked me to tell the story of when I met
Paul McCartney in his house in the 80s
and would you do the story about Paul
for some people so so I started doing it
and I met Paul and he's like any day and
this is that you know we do this to do
and I'm really full-blown Paul go to
booth and I see Lauren looking over my
shoulder and he's going oh yeah could be
could be and I'm going over to do to do
to do do and then I hear there's a
little tap I look up and it's Palmas I
just said Paul and I didn't seen him in
a while go you're holding up in Egypt it
hovers up you that he says I'm old
enough he moves to a booth he's having
dinner and he still looks over he said
I'm old enough over that he'll never
forget it he'll never forget that you
said that to him
you